[Music]
[Applause]
always great to have brian windhorst
espn senior nba writer joining us on the
program
i have
and i got to be in the minority here
brian
i still think there's a chance that kd
stays in brooklyn
how much of that would be based in
reality from what you know
that's the um sort of position that the
nets are now sort of floating out there
um
they don't like their offers and you
know it's it's a complex
reason why durant isn't getting higher
offers
he's obviously a very valued player but
there just hasn't been a bidding war
developed for him because of various
reasons
and so now they are
indicating that there may be retrenching
and we have a story in the new york post
this morning um
quoting a source close to kyrie irving
that says kyrie wants to go back to
brooklyn he never asked for a trade he's
fine with it i find that story to be
credible
at least based on what kyrie's feeling
is now what we don't have is what kevin
durant thinks about that possibility
because he started all this when he
asked for a trade
my
instinct
is to say that this is posturing from
the nets and that they're saying fine
you won't give us what we want we'll
just keep our guys and we'll
we'll we'll play it out and we can beat
you anyway
and i i have to admit that that is a
possibility but again my instinct is
still that it's a posture
has kevin durant said why he wants out
of brooklyn
not publicly i mean i've heard some of
the reasons he gave privately i'm not
going to say him now because i can't
verify him
but if your point is what was like his
ironclad good reason
i haven't heard one that i thought was
like okay that's a good reason
i just don't understand it he got a team
even if kyrie leaves
you got the coach you wanted
i i i'm you got your contract i mean
that was 11 months ago so i'm i'm i
don't know what happened or the
realization or the epiphany but
it
that's what i would love for somebody to
ask kd
and that's maybe one of the reasons why
the nets are taking this position i
think i think they probably thought
okay if he doesn't want to be here fine
we're going to go out and make a
herschel walker trade we're going to get
picks that people are going to be
talking about for years and we're going
to be getting
three or four players that can maybe
help us now even if it's not a superstar
we're gonna
we're gonna
be a much more gritty team that may
compete for the playoffs and has a great
looking future and that offer didn't
come and so now they're like well
what would be the harm in trying to run
this back um
i still think they were so miserable at
the end of last year
and this whole thing started
because they were like we can't
accept the status quo and they started
out with the hard-line negotiating
position against kyrie irving on a new
contract but i have to say
they were offering him a new contract
now we can debate we don't know what
that offer was but kyrie rejected it we
can debate maybe this has happened to
you in your career dan i've certainly
seen it to other people maybe it
happened to me someday
when you're getting offered a contract
they don't really want you to take but
they say they offer it to you but they
did offer them a contract so i can't say
that the nets
rejected the entire concept of having
kyrie on the team but
it doesn't feel to me like they wanted
that scenario to play out again
i guess we'll have to wait and see
how do these rumors about kd going to
golden state wait
how does that come to the forefront
it's a good question
in my case there's legitimate sources in
the league telling me that it's a
discussion
um
i think
first off i think that the warriors
always believe in open throttle
um the warriors have shown that they
don't care what they spend
they spent 350 million dollars this year
on this team
and the warriors have shown that they
aren't afraid to do like they went out
and got durant in the first place before
last season now granted they didn't know
if they had a championship team they
know now they do
they kicked the tires on bradley beal
like they were like hey can we do a deal
for bradley beal beale didn't want to go
there was this period where westbrook
thought beale might ask for a trade
and beale didn't and then westbrook did
westbrook got tired of waiting and then
asked for a trade out of washington
and um so that's just you know this is
the way they go about it i also think it
says a lot about steph curry
um that steph was willing to
uh
subjugate to durant in the past
and this has been a discussion inside
the warriors organization curry has been
asked about it and curry gave a
non-answer but he didn't shut it down he
didn't say hell no which he has every
right to do be like no i just won the
finals mvp no we do not need to do kevin
durant we need to bring our team back
together and try to repeat
and i think most importantly
forget about sources let's just go to
joe jacob he does this interview this
podcast interview with the athletic over
like this was late last week
a year ago he did the same you know
podcast with tim kawakami same host he
trusts him obviously and he was asked
about ben simmons was on the trade block
and he said what about ben simmons and
he goes he basically said hell no
we're not trading for ben simmons and he
was fined fifty thousand dollars for
saying ben simmons name but he said hell
no so let's again listen to actions
this time he's asked about kevin durant
he just never uses the word no in fact
he won't even say the word the name
kevin durant because he's learned he
can't say the name it'll cost you money
so he doesn't say the name but he
doesn't say no so
do i think it's likely do i think it's
you know on the on the
pie chart of things to happen do i think
it's a big slice i don't
but i also don't think that i should
dismiss it based on what i'm being told
all right if you're lebron james what
are you thinking right now
so he's got an interesting um
card in the deck which is his contract
extension he is he has never applied
contract pressure to the lakers he
applied contract pressure regularly to
the cavs he signed three contracts over
four years there they were always under
pressure he went to lakers signed a
four-year deal straight out of the gate
then two years into it signed an
extension with no option in it
so
you know the lakers have never had to
worry about lebron james and his
contract well now he's on the last year
and he can he can extend and he can't
even extend until mid-august which is a
sort of a product of the way the
pandemic played out but also convenient
for him because he gets to see the
lakers whole offseason basically before
he gets to do it and so the question for
him is
of course he wants the lakers to improve
would he like to add
kyrie irving
in place of russell westbrook i don't
think that's a controversial statement
of course he would
is it would he prefer kyrie irving other
than the other 400 players in the league
no i'm sure there'd be many more players
he'd like to play with but they can't
get those guys they can maybe get kyrie
irving so the question is
does he make it an issue in his
contract extension talks
i don't know the answer i don't know if
he's decided the answer if i'm the
lakers i'm sitting there going i've made
an offer for kyrie irving if they don't
like my offer tough luck because there's
nobody else bidding on him why should i
increase my offer
the the offer is going to be there today
it will still be there in october it
might still be there on january 1st it
might still be there on february 1st why
should i throw in
picks and everything like that's why
should i bid against myself and i can
frankly see that lakers position
and if you're especially if kyrie
starts at some point to push back and
say now i want out of here and becomes
the miserable person that the nets
didn't want
or they'll take any way to get rid of
him
and then you say well
does lebron make an issue of that in his
contract i don't think lebron
likes the feeling of being partially
blamed for the russell westbrook trade
and we've seen a
giant game of hot potato and that was no
it was him
but lebron absolutely had a role in that
and so i'm not sure he wants to be
perceived as the guy who's banging down
the door
you better trade me you better get me
kyrie irving or else i'm not signing
this i'm not sure that's the way he
wants to play it even at his age i'm not
sure that's that's what is on his mind
and we'll have to watch and see how how
that plays out brian windhorst espn
senior nba writer explain to me what the
jazz are doing
rebuilding and
as soon as they made that royce o'neill
trade the day durant asked for a trade
net get buried
that was
a complete clarion call canary in the
coal mine whatever you want to say what
they were doing and no matter what
they've said
to other teams
no one has ever
not believed they were going to trade
both of them if they could i mean you're
not going to trade them for nothing and
then they get a giant haul free to go
bear and now they want a giant haul for
donovan mitchell
and
my my guess is
and again let's judge them on their
actions let's not judge them on their
words forget what danny and just said
publicly let's judge on their actions
they have traded
two star two starting players one of
them a star
this offseason both of them for draft
picks the players that they got back
from minnesota are all role players on
expiring contracts they were going to
want draft picks and
you know miami can offer them players
and a couple of draft picks um you know
you could do a donovan mitchell trade to
brooklyn as part of a three or four team
deal where they would get ben simmons
back because donovan mitchell and ben
simmons can't be on the same
team with their their contract rules
but again let's judge them by their
actions their actions is they want draft
picks and the players
will take the player if he's okay but we
want the picks
the knicks have the picks
and you know executives in the league
believe
that
this everything that the jazz are going
to do between now and when they trade
donovan mitchell is an effort to get the
knicks to pay the most premium price
yeah i you know i know that we love for
click clicks to say the lakers and
knicks whenever it's hey somebody could
be traded and uh somebody could be
signed it's always nicks and lakers i i
really feel like the knicks
they seem like they're the real player
in here for donovan mitchell and you
know he was from greenwich or the
greenwich area and i don't know if he
cares about playing for the knicks but
you know you got brunson in there if
they keep r.j barrett um
feels like that they could actually have
something there
yeah i mean the knicks have eight
first-round picks that they're allowed
to trade uh four of their own and four
other teams
and again let's just be honest here
if you're going to trade for a team's
draft picks you know unprotected picks
the knicks are a good team to trade for
they have not shown an ability to build
a consistent winner if you owned their
dr now they never get lucky in the
lottery
but if you've owned their draft picks
for the last 20 years you'd have like a
whole bunch of lottery picks so again if
you're the jazz you're thinking
can we get the heat involved enough
can we get the nets and sons in a
three-way trade involved enough
to
get
the knicks to make a crazy bid
uh you know they got the
the timberwolves to pay a huge price for
gobert all these unprotected picks and
stuff and nobody's really sure i mean
there were teams who were definitely
talking
to them about gobert there were other
teams interested but no team willing to
pay that price
they were able to achieve
an incredible premium without
getting the bidding war they might
actually get a bidding war for donovan
mitchell but i think the knicks if if
they value him
you know to this level i think the
knicks can get it done
now we can debate on how much better
that makes them i think they missed the
play-in tournament by like six games
last year uh if i recall so even if
donovan mitchell helps them win
seven more games which would be a huge
number for any player to come in you
bring in lebron james and his prime
maybe he's winning you
12 more games i mean it asks for that
kind of uh spread would be outsized even
for donovan mitchell but let's just say
he is awesome next year and they win
seven more games he's responsible for
seven more wins
you're still in the play intern yeah
do you do you do you trade five
first-round picks
for a player like that and the answer
for the knicks who've been searching for
a star
since carmelo was in his prime the
answer dan maybe yes and that's what i
think the jazz are going to put them to
the test on
could you run the knicks better than the
knicks are being run
i would take a very fat consulting fee
to come in and make suggestions and then
leave
but i'll tell you
one thing i would instantaneously do is
i would move their headquarters out of
westchester out of westchester
because
repeatedly i talked to agents and
players who complain about that
uh i i don't under the all these players
want to live in the city and they've
completely taken the advantages of the
city out of it
and it's i don't know how big of a
factor it is but it's a contributing
factor
to um
to uh to to why they've struggled with
free agents
um
but you know
they're they're they're a sleeping giant
and it's
it's really unbelievable that the league
has had the success it's had when their
team in their biggest market has been so
freaking
bad
and for that stretch in the 2010s
lebron and steph curry carried the nba
they were getting 30 million viewers for
finals games 30 million
in a league where the lakers and knicks
were routine the lakers knicks and bulls
were missing the playoffs
year after year after year it the knicks
not being good has been like a weight on
the nba's ankle and so
if you're the knicks and you say well
listen
the top end if you trade for donovan
mitchell with with jalen brunson maybe
you have a great season and you win 48
games
that's a dream if they could get
multiple seasons of mid to high 40 wins
and have a chance to win a playoff
series
like is that gonna make anybody forget
uh the 70s knicks who won the titles no
but it would be a departure from where
they've been for 20 years they've won
one playoff series in my adult lifetime
basically
i think you think you could run the
knicks better than the knicks are being
run i wouldn't take the job i would take
i would take
a consulting fee but i wouldn't i would
not take the job i don't care how much
money has lebron ever yelled at you
oh yeah i mean yelled like screamed like
he would scream at his son no
but he's been mad at me let me tell you
about the time where my newspaper i
didn't have anything to do with this but
when he when he bought a house as a
rookie in akron ohio he
and the the akron beacon journal where i
worked at the time ran the address
of the house so you just bought now
obviously it wasn't going to stay secret
forever but they not only did they run
the address
but they put a map a graphic map just in
case you wanted to drive by it like that
afternoon here's how you get there let's
just say
he didn't like that
and there have been times where he's
been pretty upset at me
so it happens in the course of uh
you know i've i've seen him through i've
i've seen him through go some of his
worst time in some of his best times so
i was there the i wasn't in the hospital
or anything but i was there the night
his son ronnie was born and he was
having to explain to me
he had to you know he was leaving
training camp and he had to explain why
he was leaving training camp and like he
an interview was arranged and he told me
you know he didn't know his father
he told me that he was going to give his
son his name which he's later said he's
regretted which is why he goes by brawny
instead of bronte lebron jr
and um
he told me he was going to be the father
to this son that he that he didn't have
and that's sort of maybe a cliche thing
that you do if you grow up without a
father but he's done it look at the kind
of father he's been to brawny and he's
worked he's dedicating part of his
career here
to be there so that he can help ronnie
potentially get into the nba and be
successful in the nba i mean
um
you know so that sort of journey those
sorts of things yeah there's been
individual moments i remember
going to him after
the game uh four of the 2016 finals
where the cavs fell down 3-1 and i
remember looking on my phone and because
we didn't know in the moment that
draymond had hit lebron in between the
legs there it was sort of after the game
people started looking at the video and
you know the the locker room was dead
damn dead
and i walked over with the video and
showed him on my phone the video and i
remember him watching it and then
pushing the scroll bar back and watching
it two or three times i don't even think
he knew
that draymond had hit him there if he
did he'd forgotten it
and you know
he you know i just remember like those
moments when he was at his lowest and
and that
uh and how he was like wait a minute
something might happen here so
that's the stuff that i remember more
than you know the stories that i wrote
that pissed him off or stuff i said that
pissed him off um
his relationship with the media has
changed a lot over the years now he is
the media
um it's a little bit different he
doesn't quote unquote need the media
like he used to so the relationship is
different but
those are those are the moments i'll
remember stuff like that
always great to talk to you brian i know
you've been busy thank you very much for
making time have a great weekend that's
brian windhorst espn senior nba writer